[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Ross Tucker a good buddy Westwood won
CBS sports college football analyst and
host the Ross Tucker football podcast
you can find him on social media at
rosstucker NFL alright the running back
position
how do we solve it or do we need to
solve it why are we upset
well I I can tell you why we're upset uh
we are upset because star players
who everybody drafts in the first round
on their fantasy team who everybody's
kids have their jerseys
that their money's going the wrong way I
mean Dan the salary caps going up every
year by a pretty significant amount and
running back contracts are going the
opposite direction that's tough for guys
to stomach and I I don't blame them and
by the way I don't blame the teams
either right like if you're the New York
Giants Dan and you can get take one this
year for 10.1 and next year for whatever
that is 12.2 yeah why why why would you
give them 16 million a year in a
long-term contract you wouldn't right so
the franchise tag is a major major issue
here although you know what Dan you know
what might even be worse forsake Juan
and Jacobs and these guys
I'm not sure they'd get more money even
if they were on the open market that's
the scary thing I mean the teams
utilizing the franchise tag is a whole
other NFL PA topic to get rid of the
franchise tag blah blah blah but the
fact that even if saquan and Jacobs were
free agents that I don't think they
would get a lot more than this that's
got to be the part that's really
concerning for running backs and their
agents yeah I don't know the owners
aren't going to try to help the running
back you know the the league is
predicated on passing now you have
running quarterbacks here so your
running back is not the he's going to
carry the ball 25 to 30 times he might
get that many touches but the position
has changed just like the middle
linebacker position has changed if you
don't have to have that running back you
don't have to have that middle
linebacker there nobody's talking about
the plight of middle linebackers are
they
no not really and I'll tell you this my
by the way that's primarily because they
don't draft them in fantasy football I
think but I'll I'll say a couple things
Dan number one if you really think about
it right
it starts when they're way younger like
good running backs should be able to
come out after their freshman year
definitely sophomore year of college
right like some of these guys saquon
Barkley and some of these guys we've
seen recently having to play that third
year of college football Leonard
fournette it's ridiculous I mean and
then what really I I think
um bothers me personally is
The Five-Year contract yeah for first
round picks and then the franchise tag I
mean Dan do you realize that if the
Giants tags take one this year which
they did if they tag them again next
year that's seven years okay
that's saquon Barkley doesn't have the
ability to hit a market and decide where
he wants to live uh see how much money
he can make something's not right there
I mean this isn't baseball these are
running backs seven years is an entire
running back career right and this guy
can't one time not once be able to like
everybody else in life go out and see
what they're worth and see what
employers might be interested in what
they might offer him
well I know it sounds like an injustice
but the owners aren't going to be
benevolent souls and philanthropic and
go you know what if our suggestion is if
you have a separate salary cap for
quarterbacks then maybe you could spread
the wealth Elsewhere on a team and maybe
the running backs could be compensated
but I do like the idea if they could
come out after their freshman year in
college I I like the idea but what's the
possibility that college football in the
NFL are are going to be together on that
oh not real good it would have to be a
lawsuit like Maurice Claret tried it
would have to be something of that ilk
um I will say this though it's
interesting because you hear some people
say running backs don't matter I
struggle with that Dan I mean if you
watch a Browns game you can't tell me
that Nick Chubb doesn't make a
difference in the outcome of those games
or Titans with Derrick Henry or ask the
Niners I mean the Niners gave up draft
picks Dan as you know for the right to
pay McCaffrey 16 million a year and you
can't tell Niners fans after they got
McCaffrey last year that he didn't make
a difference in the outcome of some of
those games and what's really strange
you know Dan I played mainly Center and
guard right and I wasn't great but
there's guards now that are making 20
million dollars a year or more
I mean if you would have told me when I
was playing Dan from 01 to 2008
with our running back speed like Travis
Henry Willis McGahey Stephen Davis when
I was a Washington Emmett Smith when I
was with the Cowboys if you would have
told me hey Ross like 20 years from now
um guards are gonna be getting paid
double what running backs get paid I'm
I'm not sure I think maybe the pendulum
has swung too far I love Chris Lindstrom
the right guard for the Falcons Quentin
Nelson the left guard for the Colts is a
good player I'm not sure I think that
they're twice as valuable or have twice
as much of an impact on the outcome of
NFL football games if I said you could
have Josh Jacobs or saquon Barkley and
time up with a long-term deal
I would probably say saquon because I
think he's a little bit more explosive
and more productive in the passing game
but Jacob's had a heck of a year it
feels like saquon's kind of been up and
down and that Jacobs had a couple bad
years but then last year Jacobs was
awesome but and you do have two
quarterbacks here Ross who their success
is predicated on how good their running
backs have been Jimmy Garoppolo is going
to be the quarterback in Vegas he needs
Josh Jacobs Danny dimes uh he does not
get that contract extension without
saquon Barkley I'm I'm glad you brought
that up Dan so by the way imagine that
right imagine your sequan and the whole
offense runs through you and you can't
get a 12 million a year offer but the
other guy who was calling the plays in
the Huddle to run the offense through
you either a run or a pass to you it
gets 40 million dollars a year I mean
that's tough but the question now Dan is
what do these guys do and to your point
okay because I think you made a good one
they have to get something more than
just playing one year for 10.1 right so
they can't get a long-term deal anymore
but they can get more money on a
one-year deal or they can get a one-year
deal
that inserts in there a clause that they
can't be tagged again I think these guys
need to be willing to skip maybe even
games to get those Clauses and then
there's a whole other thing we could
talk about I don't think these teams
want to play games without these guys
they're not going to win very many games
without these guys so they could report
and sign the tender get their money but
oh man because they weren't at training
camp my hamstrings real sore and tight I
don't know if I can play this first game
or the second game sore hammy man
uh Before I Let You Go we're talking to
Ross Tucker Westwood One CBS Sports
um
you know the teams don't uh report the
same day for training camp why why is it
why isn't there a unilateral this is
when training camp starts and everybody
shows up at the same time
good question the answer is there are
rules
negotiating the CBA between the NFL and
the NFL PA how many days before the
first game
your rookies can report and how many
days before the first game your veterans
can report different teams handle it
differently the seven that are reporting
today the rookies they're they're using
every day they got Dan they're taking
every day as soon as we can get those
guys back and start working with them
and grind them bring them back there's
other teams that think yeah I don't know
if that's really what's best for them or
our coaches I don't know if we really
want them back that early let's wait
another week so the teams that are doing
it today with their rookies they are
within the rules the other teams have
just decided that that's not really in
the best interest of your organization
to have the rookies report this early
great to talk to you as always buddy
thank you absolutely thank you Dan
that's Ross Tucker Westwood One CBS
Sports NFL college football analyst and
former NFL offensive lineman Ross Tucker
football podcast you can find him on
social media at rosstucker NFL